okay so let's talk about the most
important let me start with
um so how are you feeling
oh uh I'm feeling much better today but
uh yeah it was super weird yesterday
like seeing
you know pictures and stuff from the
premiere and not being there
I was very strange but yeah I got to do
the screening something like little
premieres in in Europe so that was cool
yeah you were you did get to at least it
was at the tail end of the trip yeah and
you know of course that that's where I
got it and like by traveling around and
talking to all the people and so yeah
yeah listen this is just the new Norm uh
you know and uh you're not the only
filmmaker I've spoken to who got it at
the end of a tour yeah um you are it's a
long list of people so uh what room are
you at is this like your screening room
at home yeah or my little home office
kind of thing so facing this way I have
my desktop facing that way I can watch
movies and stuff yeah so what you're
basically saying is when you were
working on Shazam this is the room that
you were working on it in
no I mean then I was at Warner Brothers
you know uh for the editing and
everything and yeah well I meant more
before you started filming this is
probably the room you were developing
everything and yes yeah so before uh we
moved down to Atlanta for for prep
really starting yeah so uh listen I
we're talking about the main reason we
get to talk today is because I wanted
about IMAX
um as I've said repeatedly and every
other time someone will hear me say it
that's my favorite way of watching a
movie
um and I have many memories of IMAX
theaters and where I saw what and when
so I want to know from you do you have a
favorite IMAX memory of seeing a movie
in a movie theater that really left a
strong impression on you I only saw IMAX
in the the US you know I never saw it in
Sweden when I lived there
um I I think they have them but I I
never saw not where I lived
um now I think here one of the
I mean I thought
um what's it called Dunkirk was uh
really cool I mean Christopher Noah is
like he's the IMAX guy you know shooting
on the real film cameras and everything
and you know
um
it would be awesome to try that at some
point you know being out there in Amex
looking at those big cameras and
everything and yeah
oh sorry no no no so I think I think
Dunkirk because that was a somewhat
early one from I don't remember what the
first one was but
I just thought that one worked so well
because I mean so much of it is in the
full IMAX because it's like it's it's
very little dialogue so they could just
shoot it with the the giant cameras so
much do you have a favorite theater in
La that you like watching movies in um
specifically IMAX I think I think I've
only
mostly been at the Universal CityWalk
um
yeah
what are the like the best ones here uh
James Cameron told me years ago that he
likes the AMC Burbank 16 which is where
um yeah I've been
there but maybe I haven't seen anything
in IMAX there but do they have the full
film and everything film Project yeah
the City walk is uh excellent uh because
it's you know it's one of those full-on
movie theaters and the uh Burbank AMC 16
is is great it is a really fantastic
theater but it's not like City Walk City
walks like those old school science
museum type yeah real you know what I
mean yeah and and Burbank has been sort
of retrofitted but they're both great
great theaters you know I've been to AMC
16 many times but yeah I don't think
I've seen anything in IMAX there
next time you go see something there uh
maybe even your movie once you're uh
feeling good right out there do like a
little you know a thing audiences
clearly have a choice on where they're
going to see a movie and your movie's
about to come out in IMAX so what do you
want to tell people as to why they
should see your movie on an iMac screen
I mean it's the most sort of it's the
biggest screen the most sort of
immersive thing and I and I like the
IMAX sound as well I mean you do a
separate IMAX mix for it just because
it's such a different configuration from
uh uh from the normal ones
um
now it's just I mean so much of it is
just the size and like just the how
involved in it you are yeah actually you
touched on this a little bit and I
wanted to go a little deeper if you
don't mind a lot of times people don't
realize like the average person doesn't
understand when you finish the movie and
you get your VFX shots and everything
there's still a lot of work to do in
post-production getting a movie ready to
be in a movie theater can you sort of
talk about what you do specifically for
an IMAX release that is different than a
normal theater yeah I mean you do a
separate sound mix I mean IMAX doesn't
have like subwoofers for instance
because they have such big speakers that
you don't need it you know so you don't
need an LFE Channel and you have like a
sort of a different configuration of
speakers so you have to do a separate
mix and then the image is worked on as
well but that's something that IMAX does
like they have their own process for it
um that I guess is kind of secret or
something so so what happens is like
that they'll do their sort of conversion
Timex and show it to you and then you
know if you if there's anything you
don't like about it you can you know
give notes or whatever but I've I don't
think I've ever had any notes because
it's just it looks great every time yeah
did you go to I'm assuming you went to
their headquarters to watch
um so that theater is where we often do
some of our screenings we did a
screening there uh I'm trying to explain
most people don't get to go there but
sitting in that theater uh it's kind of
nice yeah it's it's a fantastic theater
yeah and it's cool that they have the
the
the two versions so you can sort of
check out both the the you know the they
have the big the fanciest one but then
they also have this sort of
I don't want to call it lesser one but
but it is a little lesser than the
fanciest one yeah the the big screen is
uh I believe laser projection like the
whole top of the line you know kind of
things
yeah no yeah that that one's the the
absolute best just speaking about for
the movie for a split second when you
think about all the VFX that you did and
all the stuff that you
um worked on to for the Shazam sequel
which sequence ended up being the one
that was are we ever gonna finish this
is it gonna look as good as I'm
imagining it's gonna look in my head you
know that you know what I mean yeah it
wasn't so much sequences more like shots
that took forever and um
you know you always want to run out of
time and like have to fix things I mean
the the one
that was probably one of the very last
shots to come in is like when they all
gather at the bridge you know and he's
like oh we only have what you know they
all fly in and land and everything
the big issue there was Mary because she
flies in uh and you know she's so she
starts out as a Digi double and then it
turns into the actress Grace on wires uh
being lowered down and landing and that
handoff just was not working
um because it's like usually when you go
from a Digi double to a real person it's
probably it's like in a quick move or so
you know things get hidden by motion
blur and this was just a very smooth
very slow landing and it just did not
work and we were like
you know talking to the VFX guys and
everything like to redo the whole thing
like to to redo the digital and
everything was was going to be so much
so expensive and takes so much time and
we were just at the right at the end of
the schedule so what we ended up doing
was we added a bunch of smoke that's why
she goes through a smoke cloud so as she
goes through that smoke that's when she
goes from Digi to real uh but she's but
it's it's sort of a nicely integrated
like when she goes through the smoke her
body like pushes it away and everything
so it's I mean if you don't know but
it's a Band-Aid I I think it works but
it it's totally just like let's cover it
up oh it's not working with adding smoke
and there's there that happens a lot you
know especially towards the end it was
like oh this shot is not getting there
let's add some lens flares or camera
shake or something just to hide it you
know but yeah I know that one was one
that was
took forever
um to
so yeah it was today we were just not
getting there so add smoke you know it's
so funny because that shot I know
exactly what shot you're talking about I
would have never guessed that was a
Band-Aid I just figured mission
accomplished then but yeah I mean that
there's a lot of things like that you
have to do in a movie and hopefully
audiences just think it's all
intentional sure so what you're trying
to say is JJ's lens flares in his first
Star Trek movie uh helped him a lot yeah
probably helped him a lot exactly listen
I'm not going to keep you on I just
wanted to touch on the IMAX of it all